this is a production of Cornell
University
okay
thank you Jason for that introduction
and thank you everyone for coming
to listen to my seminar um this is a
partial completion of my B exam as well
um so it's incredibly special to me
um as mentioned my topic or my seminar
is broadening the base of Apple genetics
a study of traits using malice
printfolia
so before we really get into the meat of
my project itself I wanted to give us
some framing information about Apple
breeding and how we got here in the
state of the world of Apple genetics and
breeding the Apple Center of origin is
thought to be in Kazakhstan in the
cosmic mountains with a population of
medium to large fruits in these
mountains with early hybridizations from
malice picata and Malice asiatica which
are thought to be possibly originally
isolated groups of malice versii which
is one of the founding species
humans then carried these larger fruited
malice the versii along the Silk Road
resulting in further hybridizations with
possibly some other Asian species such
as malice parnifolia until arriving in
Europe where there was a late intense
inters-specific hybridization with
malice sylvestress which is a
species known to be firmer and more
acidic but smaller in fruit size
later more intentional selection and
growing resulted in the malice domestica
that we are more familiar with today
which is known to be firm sweet aromatic
tart with larger fruits
so that story of domestication
and there is uh Sylvester's
so that story of domestication then led
to into hundreds of years of intentional
Apple selection and breeding by humans
to bring us here where we have amazing
cultivars such as Snapdragon and Ruby
Frost New York one and year two which
were released from Cornell rather
recently
Apple if you're unaware is a clonally
propagated species and fruit is marketed
by cultivar this has resulted in certain
cultivars becoming more widely planted
and more widely sold
um and these Coast buyers mostly have
larger fruit with lower acid higher
sweetness and they're often red in color
or have a blush
how we market and sell Apples by
cultivars have
for commercial use has resulted in a
reduction in diversity of apples that
are grown for commercial use
though breeding pools and repositories
like the one in Geneva show higher
diversity still so we have not like lost
the diversity of malice in this breeding
efforts
here we have in the graph we have the
top nine cult bars that are sold in the
US you are likely pretty familiar with
these cultivars you know Granny Smith
pink lady Golden Delicious Gala red
delicious Honeycrisp and Macintosh to
name them and Fuji
um
and these first degree relationships are
demonstrated by these gray circles and
that just means that they are otherwise
a sibling a parent or a child of these
very popular cultivars and there's
plenty of hybridization between these as
well as results in a rather reduced
amount of
cultivars commercially available and
this has resulted in some problems
specifically related around disease
and disease resistance
which brings us to my project so malice
per napolia is a West Asian species of
Apple that was possibly involved in
domestication along the Silk Road
um depicted here in a photo it would be
on the
um smaller malice species on the
left of your screen
and then you can see here on the right A
diversity panel of all of the malice for
Napoleon inside of the genetic
repository in Geneva
and you can see that Mal's per napole is
a species really runs the gamut in sorts
of fruit shaped color and size and so
it's a rather interesting species the
specific mouse pernipolia that I have
used in my study is malice per Napoleon
19651 which from here on out I am just
going to refer to as nalospernifolia I
will trip over those numbers constantly
if I don't
um
this individual has been used as a part
of the malice core collection which
means it has been included in multiple
linkage studies and mapping studies and
as a individual it clusters with other
Asian species but not always with other
prunipolia sessions and it's
dihedgehogon profile which dihydrocos
are phenolic compounds that are of
interest in increasing beneficial Health
compounds in apple it's definitely
profile indicates that there was some
species add mixture in its background so
we're not even sure that it's actually
Metals per napolia but it is the
designation that we are currently using
and this it's of interest because of a
um because of its apparent strong fire
blight resistance and
um there's a thing
and other biochemical traits as well as
its usefulness as a wild species in
genetic studies trying to understand
um novel traits from uh not
underutilized species in breeding
the other parent in this population of
trees is called New York co1 Co stands
for columnar and it is a malice X
domestica meaning it is the standard
domestic domesticated Apple that we are
familiar with it has columnar habits
meaning that it is grows very vertically
upright with short Spurs and very few
outward branches so it's more like a
pillar I have some photos of it coming
up later and in its background it has
panova which is a German cultivar
sunkris and widget Macintosh which
widget Macintosh is the origin of the
columnar Habit in Malice
and it is a large fruited individual
with yellow skin and a slight blush to
it and other characteristics I will be
listing later so these two individuals
are quite different which results in a
rather interesting display of trait
segregations that I will be touching on
so as a general summary of this
population like I said it was a
cross-made between New York co1 and
Malice pernafolia
and it resulted in 600 seeds that were
then germinated a number of them died
due to a lethality Gene and resulted in
a validated population of 423
individuals which I validated to using
GBS markers and PCA principal component
analysis and that broke down into 228
226 standard trees and 197
um
columnar trees which is about 50 50
which is what we would expect in the
segregation ratio and then there's dwarf
types within that I'm not really going
to be touching on tree architecture
during this talk though there are some
interesting
um components of that that I will be
discussing in Publications and findings
later
foreign so briefly this talk is going to
focus on three things uh fruit storage
and I will be talking about storage
genes and genotypes associations and
then an rna-seq experiment that was used
to clarify kind of what's going on in
storage fruit organic acidity genetics
um pH and detergentful acid was measured
associations were found and then I'll be
discussing deviations and distortions
unique to this population or unique to
this breeding pool in general and then
lastly fruit quality traits which I will
just be touching briefly on fruit size
however I measured a number of other
traits including bricks presence of
brusset and phenolic compounds along
with several others
and isn't this such a pretty image this
their siblings and have very different
colors flowers but they're both columnar
this population is really stunning in
flowering and fruiting just in kind of
the breadth that it covers and it's
always fun to walk through
so I followed this population for um
four years three pretty intensely and
then one with some
um extra data to get three years to
report on so in 2019 176 individuals
fruited the traits that I collected are
listed there including total acid pH
bricks phenolic compound shape and size
color and then fruits and cuticle
disorders 2020 288 individuals fruited
and all those previous traits were
collected as well as mass and then I
added a color rimner to the technical
mix so I could measure more accurate
color 2021 306 individuals fruited and
RNA samples were taken along with all of
that previous data and then I checked
the population for starch iodine index
at Harvest uh 2022
308 individuals fruited and I continued
collecting data for storage time
fruit size and then external
characteristics in that I was seeing
so in order to do any sort of genetic
study we need to have genotype for the
population
so this population was genotyped using
uh genome by sequencing or GDs
um and a collaboration between Cornell
USDA and housing University it was then
aligned to the Golden Delicious double
haploid reference genome and I used a
principal component analysis depicted
here on the left to I identify and
remove any outcrosses so the two points
on the far side of the charts are the
two parents and the cloud in the center
are all the progeny the 22 outcrosses
were identified and discarded and then a
further outcross was found in genotyping
later on and was also discarded before
analysis the filter settings I have are
there and it resulted
in 51 442 sites which is plenty for a
genetic study and so my genetic analysis
has been pretty robust which is exciting
so the first trait that I'm going to
talk about here is apple storage and in
the first year approving this population
only had like 22 individuals fruit in
2018 when I first got here but even in
that small subset of individuals there
was an apparent segregation of long
storing fruits that stayed well in the
cooler on par with mouse mestica and
short storing fruits some of which
sonest on the tree and some snest very
quickly in the cooler and I have quite
an interest in reducing food waste and
so I found the straight to be of great
interest
it's also important to note that since
this is an inter-specific population
and because of what we know from
domestication studies and apple fruit
firmness and the ability to store fruit
appears to be a trait that we selected
upon in the early days of domestication
and fruit breeding and so adding in this
wild species gives a kind of Novel
chance to look at some of these
domestication genes and what we should
really consider as we're working towards
using wild species and future Apple
breeding so my hypothesis is listed
there briefly genetic differences are
causing differences in storage time
phenotypes and then my questions are
listed there what genes are causing
these differences are external biotic
effects causing them and really what
effects are these genes having on the
fruit over storage time
storage is intensely researched in apple
um and
since apple is a commonly propagated
crop most of the research has been
focused on modifying the environment
surrounding the fruits whether in
growing or in storage
um and not as much Focus has been given
on genetic causes and that's mostly
because once a cultivar is released and
becomes popular we can't retract it to
fix an issue in storage and so we work
on modifying the environment around it
however I really wanted to look into the
genetic causes of storage ability that
I'm seeing in this population
so here if you've been in any sort of
intro storage class
you see a ripening curve for climacteric
fruit which apple is one you can see the
trends in respiration and growth as well
as the interplay with ethylene which is
a plant growth hormone that is heavily
tied to plants respiration plant growth
and then fruit ripening
um
with this understanding I then looked
into genes that had been previously
identified in other studies in relation
to ethylene as well as storage the
Ethylene the ethylene biosynthesis
pathway is depicted here with the genes
of interest that I'm going to talk about
in blue
ACO and ACS have been identified in
apple and somewhat well characterized
these genes have been identified and
known to affect ethylene production over
storage time
and so here's more information ACO is
located on chromosome 10. it is the
final step of ethylene biosynthesis and
has been associated with increased
ethylene production
um
for a long time ACO was considered like
not that much of a factor in storage but
more recent Studies have indicated that
it is more of a rate limiting step than
previously thought ACS is the first step
in this two-step pathway and has
previously been reported as the rate
limiting step it's located on chromosome
15 and also is increased with increase
associated with increased ethylene
production
right
but first before I got
um into that I wanted to look to see if
there were any biotic causes of these
storage differences
um in this population so Blue Mold which
is a penicillium is the most number one
it's the number one post-harvest
pathogen
um in apple storage and so I created a
subset of the population half of them
being long story individuals that I
attract at least a year previously and
half of them being short-term
individuals and tested them for Blue
Mold resistance by stabbing them with
the nail and putting penicillium
inoculum into that wound and then
placing them into an inoculation chamber
also known as a large plastic taupes
with wet paper towels to maintain
humidity and ensure inoculation and
sporulation
and from that
no complete resistance was observed so
all of the fruit did get infected with
blue mold and there however there was
some slight variation in time to
sporulation but not enough to be
significant
okay
as mentioned before ethylene is very
important in Fruit ripening and
senescence so the same subset was
brought down here to the Watkins lab
with Yosef and Chris Watkins to be
measured for internal ethylenes so a
measurement of gas was taken from the
internal seed chamber and from that no
real pattern of
um was found between the two classes so
no pattern in long story and short
storing storing however this is likely
due to the fact that the fruits
um there was ripeness differences in the
fruits um caused by its intra-specific
background I can't use standardized
ripening metrics like starch iodine
index and penetrometers because the
fruit are too small for a penetrometer
some of them will get crushed just by
the distance of penetration and
variation in starch has been observed in
wild species so I couldn't reliably use
starch iodine index 2.5 brightness
either and also sometimes the C chamber
was simply too small to accurately draw
gas out so
ethylene is still a mystery but Blue
Mold is not the cause of this resistance
or this storability
so from the three years of data I looked
at segregation ratios and
um they are depicted here they are
approximately 50 or one to one
segregation ratio which suggests a
single
um large effect Gene
which I then ran a genetic Association
using tassel and then R to plot the
results which are displayed here as a
Manhattan plot and you can see there's a
very clear and strong Peak located on
chromosome 10.
um and this p co-locates with the region
that has been associated with ACO
so to see if anything else is going on I
then genotyped the two parents for ACS
and ACO the two genes
um involved in the ethylene biosynthesis
pathway and found that in ACS both
parents near columnar one and pronifolia
where homozygous or the long storing or
the low ethylene producing alleles so
ACS does not seem to be of any effect
here which makes sense since we did not
see any Peak on chromosome 15. however
ACO the malice domestic parents New York
columnar one as the two low ethylene
producing genes but in frontifolia it
has one copy of the low ethylene
producing and one copy of the high
ethylene producing this means that the
progeny will be segregating a one-to-one
ratio between
homozygous low ethylene producing and
heterozygous so one copy of lung and one
copy or one copy of low ethylene and one
copy of high ethylene producing which
also validates this
Manhattan plot this uh genetic
Association
but I wanted to understand what was kind
of going on in this population or in
storage over time and so I outlined an
rna-seq experiment that used four
long-storm individuals which included
the long-storying parents and for
short-term individuals which included
the short storing parent which was
parnifolia
um and had collection dates that were
connected over
um physiological time of senescence so
in short storing there was three time
points that were measured a initial time
at Harvest a midpoint and then right
before senescence and then in long story
there was five time points that were
collected which had all of those plus
two additional Harvest Time points just
to further give clarification on that
gene expression curve and all of these
individuals in the study were also
validated with um their genotypes so the
short storing individuals had the
heterozygous genotypes that ACO and the
long strong individuals had the
homozygous low storing or low ethylene
producing genes at ACO
this is just kind of the workflow of the
rna-seq that I did it resulted in an
average number of breeds being over 3
million the percent of uniquely mapped
reads being at 81.43 percent
and I had 30 000 out of 52 000 of the
total annotations
um that were mapped to the peel so I
decided to take tissue samples of the
peel because it has been shown to be
more biosynthetically active than the
rest of the fruit during storage and
also the fruit tissue itself contains
lots of sugars which cause problems for
RNA extraction
um these numbers are a little bit low or
a lot of RNA sleep experiments but for a
three prime profiling experiment which
is that's what this is this is
sufficient to give us an idea and
indication of what is happening over
storage and time
so from those reads a PCA was made to
the to demonstrate the separation
between the classes and see if an
unsupervised wgcna was able to be done
so here you can see across pca1 which is
the bottom
um there's pretty good separation over
time so early collections mapped on the
right side of that chart and later
collections mapped on the left and then
across pca2 we can see a pretty clear
separation between the classes so again
long story individuals are blue and
short storing individuals are red so
this gave us indication that we could
use unsupervised wgcna
which then created this cluster charts
um the color names on the left sides of
these boxes don't really mean anything
other than names of the Clusters so you
can ignore that but
these are groups of eigenes that appear
to be associated with each other so red
means that the genes in the Clusters are
positively correlated with each other so
as eigen expression of them go up other
eigenes also go up blue is negatively
Associated so same pattern in Reverse
um and then
um and the contrast of this was between
the two classes so long and short and
the different columns here are grouped
so just comparing between long and short
individuals time which was days since
each a session had different storage
lengths because they were matched their
individual senescence and then time
Group which was the
0.25.5 0.75
and full senescence
discussed earlier
so from that
these clusters were then made to create
to demonstrate eigengine expression
patterns over time so the y-axis is the
modeled eigengine expression
um higher means higher expression lower
on the chart means lower expression and
then the x is just that time Point
Series so as you can see the short
individuals in red only have three
collection points and the long
individuals have five
and I have these two highlighted just to
demonstrate kind of what this sort of
output tells us so on the far right we
have turquoise and blue which you see
that the two classes appear to be
relatively similar in shape across time
we can assume that that is standard
biological process in storage and so I'm
not going to be looking in that cluster
for anything because they're both going
through similar expression levels and
then on the left side we have yellow and
green which have quite different levels
similar shapes but different
um
quantities of eigenchene expression and
so yellow and green might be an area
that I would look into for some causal
genes up or some Pathways of what could
be going on
foreign
all of the Clusters that I could
potentially look into the parentheses
indicate how many genes are located
inside that cluster so some are quite
large at um you know
41 000 and some are quite small at 65.
however we just we don't want to just
rely on these algorithmically decided
expression patterns in order to explain
what we're seeing so no with that
information and with the association
that I have discussed previously
um I looked into The annotation files
that were available for ethylene related
genes and I found over 300 genes and
that included transcription factors
Pathways signaling path repressors and
synthesis pathway genes from the 300
there were 30 that were differentially
expressed
in this pattern and they were
distributed across seven of those
previously pointed out modules and from
those 30 I found some of the most highly
um
uh differentially expressed so log folds
over 1.8 and a p-value over 0.005
and
from there I went back to this um
biosynthesis pathway and as you can you
can see again ACS and Eco there are the
ones that we have understanding about
and so I looked at ACS this again has no
segregation in the population and the
gene expression or the transcript
expression of that Gene is not
significantly different than
um between long story and short storing
which you would expect because there's
no genetic difference right
in ACO which we know there's a genetic
difference we would expect there to be
um a different expression but again
there's no significant difference
between the two classes however I do
want to point out here that the causal
mutation of Ace that causes the low and
low ethylene producing and high ethylene
producing phenotypes at ACO do not
change the transcript level it is a
functional mutation a missense mutation
that causes the protein resulting from
the transcript to function less so we
want to actually expect any transcriptal
differences at ACO so what are we going
to look at now because that doesn't make
sense anymore right
so
I looked at other Associated genes and
other Associated proteins and found
um this Gene Sam DC Sam is a pretty
ubiquitous protein in biosynthetic
Pathways and in ripening the DC is
decarboxylated
I always have to look decarboxylase
um but cmdc has been shown in ripening
studies to be upregulated by the
perception of ethylene so Sam is
increased the expression of Sam DC has
increased when the fruit or the tissue
is receiving ethylene and starting the
biosynthesis pathway again and here we
do see a significant difference between
the two classes where long starring
individuals have quite a bit less
transcription of this Sam DC
Gene and short storing individuals have
an increasing expression of it over time
which makes sense because in theory ACO
is
producing more ethylene in
short storing individuals and
long-strung individuals and then the
fruits are responding to this higher
ethylene concentration around them
so to look
look more into this I then looked at the
ethylene receptor and sensor genes which
do similar things they
um
sense ethylene and then start the
ethylene senescence pathway and in both
of these cases here we see a
we see a difference between short
storing and long strong individuals with
long story being significantly lower
than short storing individuals
and continuing on that these are
ethylene response factors which they are
genes that get turned on when the
senescence pathway that is controlled by
ethylene kind of overproduces and so
they try to repress that pathway so we
would again expect these to be higher
expressed in tissues that are sensing
increased levels of ethylene so I have
highlighted here this response Factor on
gene or not Gene chromosome 15. that you
can see a very clear difference between
the two types and then here on
chromosome 12 on the side of the screen
there are also two other ethylene
response factors
that show a difference between the two
classes of fruits and I really wanted to
highlight
um this one at the top because it the
long story individuals have almost no
transcription of this ethylene response
Factor while the short ones have
um transcription of it
so to kind of wrap everything up
together
um the biotic factors that I looked at
Blue molds and internal ethylene really
didn't give a lot of clarity but I was
able to map an association that
co-locates with the ACO region over
three years
position
and then when looking at the rna-seq
data we see that the fruit itself is
responding to an increased level of
ethylene that is caused by the ACO Gene
and that is backed up by the samdc gene
as well as the receptors and response
genes which are higher higher
transcribed in the short storing
individuals and lower transcribed in the
long-strung individuals
so before I move on and then again just
to reiterate
um this is of import this is of interest
and importance in inter-specific Reading
because we uh need to do some
inter-specific rating to interest new
traits but we don't really know what
negative traits are being brought in and
so this could be something that we have
to pay attention to as we do that work I
am going to try to quickly go through
stuff because I only have five minutes
um so in apple acidity is one thing that
has been researched quite intensely
um ma1 and ma3 are two genes that are
reported to control the majority of
malic acid accumulation in Malice ma1 is
reported on chromosome 16 and ma3 is on
chromosome 8. on the right there's a
very short list of
other genes reported to influence malic
acid though there is plenty more beyond
that I will just be talking about ma1
and ma3 here
so in this population there's quite a
distribution between acidity between the
two parents so this is data from 2021
though the patterns for this hold true
over all years observed and you can see
that
um New York columnar one has
significantly lower acidity than malice
per napolia
um co1
comes in at three point
3.27 grams per liter of titratable
acidity
um and prunipolia comes in at
24.44 grams per liter which just for
reference
um apples are kind of thought to be
somewhere between like 5 and 10 grams of
titratable acidity per liter
um so 150 Club New York columnar one is
actually significantly lower acidity
than kind of standard apple and then
printifolia is quite a bit high
screamingly high acid
um and all the progeny fall Within These
two parents every single year so great
candidate for genetic dissociation
because the knowledge of these two genes
the population was genotypes for ma1 and
klemnar one was found to be homozygous
dominant which would indicate that it
has a high acid phenotype which doesn't
quite make sense per napolia was found
to be heterozygous meaning it is one
high acid allele and one low acid allele
so from that we would expect a
segregation ratio of one to one of
homozygous dominant and heterozygous
however we find an actual segregation
ratio of 1 to 1.58 and that is due to
that lethality Gene that I mentioned at
the very beginning that is linked to ma1
if
ma3 was also genotyped and co1 was found
to be homozygous recessive meaning it
has a low acid genotype and printifolia
was found to be heterozygous with one
copy of high acid and one copy of low
acid and again we would expect a
segregation ratio of one to one and that
is what we observed in the population
from that I again did a genetic
Association using tassel and glm and
found this Peak located on chromosome 8
which co-locates with the ma3 region it
is interesting to report though that we
really don't see the peak on chromosome
16 that we would expect with ma1 we do
see it slightly in the pH chart but that
Peak is inconsistent over years and it's
never found in the tradable acidity even
over all three years and it shows up in
PH two out of three years
and I just want to point out again the
ranges of data titratable acidity goes
from 3 to 24 and pH goes from like 2.6
to 4.8 and so it's a lot easier to
create kind of false associations
without that granularity of data
um and so
from that
it's kind of it brings up the question
of what is going on here
um the primary acid in Malaga in Malice
is not like acid which we assume is
about 95 or upwards of 95
um however it's been found in wild
species that secondary acids such as
citric acid accounts for up to 60 of the
acid profile so to check if citric acid
is what's causing this wide discrepancy
in acidity I tried to measure citric
acid or the acidity profile and do
associations with specific acids
initially I tried an enzymatic assay
which was inconclusive I then moved to
hplc and in hboc I found no signal or it
was an unreliable signal that I could
not replicate from day today and so I
send a small subset to lulling to check
for or to use gcms to check for citric
acid and there was no citric acid signal
observed but there was a wide variation
in malic acid in the subset which kind
of which validates the high distribution
that I was showing earlier and also
accounts or informs us that the majority
of this acid is malic acid and we can
assume other acids are not really
playing a part
so like I said the acidity profile is
not due just these secondary acids
um but we know that ma3 controls the
majority of acid expression in this
population
um which kind of indicates that ma1
seems to be non-functioning in this
population or it's under repression
um New York co1 has high acid alleles
homozygous dominant for the high acid
but the lowest acid phenotype in this
entire population
so this is a bit outside of this
dissertation work but in order to
identify kind of what's going on or give
indication in conversations with Dr
Susan Brown she mentioned that ma3 seems
to control majority of
the acid in herberating populations and
so ma1 could be sequenced to identify
potential allelic variations that have
lower
expression or lower controls and then we
could identify the source of that
allelic variation to see if it's Unique
to the populations here or unique to
some of the background of one of New
York lumbner one
lastly and I'm going to try to speed
through this so I don't go away over
time
um fruit quality again I measured all of
these traits but I'm really only going
to report on fruit size
um today because it has a clearer story
so I measured fruit size as fruit height
fruit diameter and fruit mass and here
are the distributions for 2021 which
again had just the most robust data sets
so that's what I'm reporting on right
now and you can see again that the
parents are on each side of the chart
with New York lemnar one being the large
fruited one and prunofolia being one of
the smallest or the smallest in the
population with a distribution of
progeny between the two
so using that data I created another
genetic association with these three
traits and interestingly found
Peaks on chromosome 13 in both diameter
and Hypes that used
or the Peaks were located at the same
snip so
and the peep that is on chromosome
13 in mass is very nearby the snip as
well
um this is of note because no fruit size
lists that have been identified on
chromosome 13 for Apple yet
um there's also been there was also
Peaks identified in this Association for
on chromosome 5 for fruit height from
zone two for fruit diameter and
chromosome 3 for fruit Mass
so briefly in summary I talked a lot
about fruit storage and what is going on
behind the scenes over storage time I
presented a wide variety in Fruit
acidity and genetic associations and
controls in this population and then
also presented some data on fruit size
and all of this together kind of tells
the story of using inter-specific
breeding in apple breeding and also
traits that could be paid attention to
as we're doing that and also somewhat
goes against the standard idea of
interest-specific Apple breeding which
is that all intra-specific hybrids are
small fruited and high in tannins high
in acidity low in sugar all these
negative traits and this project kind of
tells a story that in interspecific
apple breeding with careful parental
selection and some patience you are able
to really get some
uh decent sized and decent tasting
apples after one generation that could
be then used in future breeding with
some of these useful traits
I'd be remiss to not acknowledge all the
people that have helped in this um
project and in my just um in my research
namely Dr Susan Brown and Kevin Maloney
in the Apple breeding lab in Geneva who
um their mentorship has been invaluable
to me
um all of my collaborators my committee
members the current lab that I'm in um
in Geneva with Jason Londo and then the
great braiding lab which have been great
friends and collaborators and my funding
through polar Grant instrumental Novak
and then none of this happens in a
vacuum and so I want to thank and
acknowledge all of my friends and family
that have supported me through all this
and kept me sane as I'm staring at
apples for 16 hours a day and with that
I think I'm done and I would take any
questions
good question so
storage is a human construct it's an
article Constructor yeah in these wild
populations you're finding variation in
genes and impacts storage which one that
existed when they were evolving and so
forth so what what nature is selecting
for some of these differences in genetic
tracers shown up in stores like what
what's the selection pressure in nature
if you're looking at these Wild Spaces
is there like an optimal time for these
apples to hang on a tree before they're
consumed you know what's going on there
yeah I mean okay so the question is
um like storage is a human construct and
so during domestication how were these
storage related genes selected upon
right okay
um and I think the answer is they
weren't necessarily selected on for
storage they were selected for the
ethylene um senescence
um effects so in this population some of
these trees finesse on the tree and so
if you think in nature those snessing
rotting fruits are not very useful to
animals because they're breaking down
the sugars are breaking down the
starches are gone and so as animals were
consuming them they likely selected for
ones that did not rot immediately and
then the seeds spread and then as humans
moved them along the Silk Road probably
something more akin to storage was
selected for just movability and
transportation of fruits you don't want
your bag to be full of rotten apples and
so you would discard those and keep the
ones that stayed sound over time right
yeah
yes yeah thank you for the
representation how do you select the
storage period for how long the two in a
short and the long-term source so the
question is how were the classes defined
between short and long story
um so the long story individuals were
basically identified as saying sound and
storage from Harvest which is September
October until
discard and cleaning which was April May
so not as long as apples can be stored
but the short storing individuals also
Nest within three months of harvest and
so there was a pretty clear separation
between those two different types
um it was kept at 4C so pretty standard
oh that question was just what was the
storage temperature
just out of curiosity of the result did
you taste any of the
app oh yes I tasted almost all of them
um some of them are um awful and hurt
your mouth to consume as hungry can
attest to and some are actually quite
Pleasant
um with pretty good texture sweetness
and acidity that you know is very
similar to a commercial Apple but yeah
some are very high tannic and
um high acidity and so they hurt
oh
bad any questions from Geneva
yes a lot of questions just comments
okay
um regarding the ml1
I think you can look at their
um genetic effect
on the inter
a little interactions
4ml went for both ml1
and ms3
um they are dominant gene for highest
so in your population
you have a homologous
high acid for
foreign
[Music]
yeah
the other parent is you have a health
record right
right yep heterozygote
so that means
your population
[Music]
will not surrogate
for ml1
in terms of the in terms of
in terms of their healthy levels
does it controlled by that
by ml1
so that's why you don't see it
you don't see the effect of email what
okay
so I mean you're saying that because of
the dominant acid allele that can come
from either parents that we would not
see a difference in expression right not
a lot expressions
just a little functionality sense
okay
yeah we could potentially do an allele
um expression difference with those
yeah for the for the ma3 that's the
perfect because you have both both of
them are headed like this
so you see it in surrogate
and then you see the effect
yep so that is that explain your data
very well
good job
thank you
okay we're about out of time would you
like to hang around and I'm sure there's
more things back there to eat so thank
you all very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu